coach's corner for any surface and every
season Continental Tire coaches corner
will bring us doc rivers there's a
continental tire that delivers superior
performance and unparalleled safety give
your vehicle an upgrade with
Continentals maximum performance tires
for more info on the tire that's right
for you check out Continental Tire com
from speedway to driveway continental
put you in the driver's seat Doc Rivers
Clippers head coach joining us on the
program a doc you grew up in Chicago
real White Sox fan this has been very
difficult for me there oh my well I'm
cheering for the cups and it's it's not
been easy you could just say look you're
white sox fan and you can't root for
them if you're going to move for a
nationally team you're rooting for the
Dodgers that you could do that Cub fans
would respect that yeah I know but it's
a great story and I do know Joe Maddon a
little bit even though my very good
friend is on the other team the coach of
the Indians stare Francona we got to
know each other really well when we're
in Boston but you know in Chicago I'm
from Chicago and I think it'd be good
for the city did you go to White Sox
games yeah I went to a lot of white sox
James Comiskey Oh Comiskey Park you
haven't seen the worst raid the White
Sox ever made do you know that which
what it was no they let Harry Caray go
to the coast that's a that's a fact
Detroit did you have a favorite white
sox player growing up Dick Allen oh man
he was scary that bat that bat was
bigger than me he he must have had one
of the biggest bands to ever play in
Major League Baseball or they have you
ever it was amazing he could swing that
thing I think kiru and a generation of
kids in mid like 35 be struck out it was
great you you'd carried up to the plate
like it's a club my dad is unbelievable
everyone in my neighborhood use of
to [ __ ] and we couldn't hit go figure
and.and you had he would be smoking
cigarettes in the dugout I love those
those the white with the red pinstripe
uniforms at the White Sox had that was
with Bill Veck of the owners you know
they had shorts remember they only on
shorts one night that was bad that was
bad as Greg Greg luzinski and Harold
Baines that's exactly right jorge orta
were you a a Bulls fan at all groaning I
was actually a Knick fan growing up you
know I would be like I guess in today's
generation if the brian james in the
waiting wave was your two favorite
players and then they played on the same
team you were to become a heat fan yeah
well for me it was a film I rosenwald
Frazier and when they were traded when
Illustrated to the Knicks for me as a
kid I literally almost lost my mind like
my two guys forgot Leon the same thing
and people wondered if that back court
could work because you know you had Earl
that had to have the ball he was a score
and you know Clyde being one of the
great point guards in NBA history but
that yet the what's the role that the
coach plays when you have two stars on a
team I mean we've seen this with
Oklahoma City with Westbrook and Durant
maybe didn't get along now Golden
State's got all of these players what's
the what's your job when keeping
everybody happy when you got a couple of
guys who have to have the ball the job
is to get them to focus on why they're
playing you know their goals and you
know it's almost like a week we got Paul
Pierce and Ray Allen and Kevin we we got
them at the right time then they they're
ready to win so it was easy and I
thought red tiles and did the same thing
would with walking Earl they were ready
to win they had played forever and it
was time for both of them to win and so
it was easy but do you think the Durant
what role do you think this you got to
win championships to be considered one
of the great players of all time what
role do you think that played in LeBron
going to Miami and Durant going to
Golden State
well the probably played a big role ah
but this there's really nothing wrong
with that when you when you think about
it I mean you should want to win the
title but no I've always laughed I was
an average player I wanted to win to
what Justice are you always you know
it's funny when we won the title and I
think you asst Eddie House in 2008
someone asked him aren't you happy for
Kevin and Paul anything the public radio
is that just those three guys and so but
it is good you should want to win you
know you should want to wait in the way
you want to win and that's how LeBron
wanted to do it and that's how direct
wants to do it it's our job to try to
make them not do it you know that's
that's the Clippers show we hold on to
our childhood memories and whether it's
a player or a team and I maintain that
it's hard for LeBron James to move into
the top five because those who cover the
game probably had their favorites
growing up and to me LeBron doesn't have
to do anything else he's going to but I
think he's one of the top five players
of all time and I'm talking about I know
it's hard to do generational but I just
look at what he's done and you know he's
going to be in contention for an MVP and
another title again this year would you
allow LeBron to be a top-five player of
all time yeah he is number one and
you're right though the players of the
paths are bigger than life to us and
it's almost impossible for us to ever
move a current player in the front of
him and so just statistically speaking
and visually since I was the coach of
the southington we had a 3-2 lead now
Washington score 45 yeah I is in the top
by there's no doubt when you put in just
the brothers a different game I mean
we're so used to seeing still looking
graceful when that used to seeing you
still look so powerful and so I think
that rubs people wrong but LeBron
just typically championship wise he's
one of the top five players ever play
the game he's Doc Rivers they opened the
season with it went over the Blazers
they got a game on Sunday against the
jazz joining a Stan Patrick show Charles
Barkley said klay Thompson is the second
best player in the league what do you
make it hoo boy I I think this is
probably gonna be my first time ever
disagreed Charles Barkley that's not
true but he's often is a wonderful
player who's sick uh rules first lebron
lebron right yeah after that it's a long
line I mean it's tough to say a guy
that's been the back-to-back MVP that
another player on his team is better you
know that's that's that's a hard
argument that there's a lot of guys a
kid even I mean there's so many guys in
the league right now the league's in a
great place so the fact that we can have
these debates are great you know
Westbrook wouldn't agree with that I can
tell you that no well Kawhi Leonard
wouldn't either I'm sure harden wouldn't
you know I mean I think there's quite a
few guys that are there who could
qualify for number two but I think
LeBron I mean the fact that he thinks
that just clay is better than Steph
Curry was interesting as well now he's a
better all-around player but i do think
i can find a klay Thompson I have a hard
time finding another Steph Curry yeah
that's exactly right it it may be hard
to find another klay Thompson as well
but that's still that makes him second
you know it's just it's tannish so many
good players i mean i have several my
team they would put up an argument so
it's just a great time to be in the NBA
we were looking at the list of guys who
scored 50 in a game and you know there's
some random i know what was your career
high you were probably a 38-point guy or
something boy that's pretty good 37 0 37
wife did it twice but I think Jamal
Crawford is gone gone over 53 times yeah
you can see that he's what he's a great
shooter the professional scorer I what
was the conversation you had with Redick
about where all the
players how did that conversation come
up that you got to well I guess Kevin
love's the best white guy in the league
but where are all the white basketball
players you don't know how we we started
it uh you know if it was funny you know
JD and I started talking about it and
you know it's like how did they all go
to the major leagues you know where are
they but they're coming I mean when you
go to a you basketball you know there's
all races fighting right now with our
young generation and so you'll see more
and more players from from from all
different races and that'll make our
league better but you also look at the
style I don't know if the NBA are you
trying to adopt but the Warriors do at
all that's time can you no no I think
the Warriors do that better than
everyone else and I think teams are
making a mistake if they try to be the
Warriors you know you're not going to
outshoot the Warriors they have Durant
Curry and klay Thomas so you have to be
the best team you are we have size we
have speed we have F lettuce ISM we can
be dominant at times offensively so we
have to be us now shooting is more
important than our league than it ever
has been and you do need shooting so you
have to try to get as much shooting as
you can but you have to do it through
the way you play not the way Golden
State place you had this in Boston where
you knew that window of opportunity was
closing when you when you had the big
three but they were you know later on in
their careers have you gotten to that
point with the Clippers with that window
of opportunity closing you know we are
young still you know Chris is 31 and
then everyone else is pretty young so I
guess the answer is no but I've always
entered the season with that and I want
my players to always think that that
answer is yes you can never take a year
for granted or your career for granted
and if you're one of those teams that
have the chance to win you better do it
now you can't think well next year the
team I used as a great example to that
Dan is Oklahoma
Oklahoma made made it to the finals and
everyone assumed they would be back year
at the year at the year they never made
it back to the finals and so if you're
one of those things and I do think we're
one of them you have to try to seize a
moment because there may never be
another moment did you see that
Westbrook and Durant maybe weren't
friends because now we find out they
didn't even he didn't even talk he
didn't even tell Westbrook he was
leaving to go to golden state like you
know as the opposing coach did you ever
sense that maybe they weren't buddy
buddy I didn't I saw at times they
didn't fit you know we played him in the
playoffs to one year and had a great
chance to beat him and end up losing and
I mean you can just with visually watch
the way they played you know that at
times they didn't fit or get along plane
but I actually felt off the court uh
they wouldn't friends but they got along
pretty well actually then I honestly
think they probably did anyway and I
think at the end of the day when Katie
decided to leave you know I better if
you could do it over again it probably
would have told Westbrook but that's not
an easy leaf it lets like that did you
hit did you get along with all your
wizard teammate what happens if you
don't like a teammate you play with them
you know I like most of my teammates I'm
sure I'm sure there are a couple i
didn't like it especially at times you
know i was a defensive player so if you
were just an awful offensive player i
probably did enjoy playing with you at
times having said that you still played
with him there there's a value to
everybody the coach is not putting the
guy on the floor if he didn't think he
could help the team and so you should
try to just focus on what he did well to
help not to think they didn't do so you
didn't like Dominique Wilkins at times
Monsieur Gordon left Dominique actually
was a really good defender are you
selectively
he pick and choose when he wanted to
play defense yes he did but I tell you
let's go a lot of points for us so he
was forgiven hey great to talk to you
good luck this season doc thank you all
right thank you nice darn you dad that's
our Doc Rivers Clippers head coach they
got to Sunday's game against the utah
jazz Continental Tire brings us the
Continental Tire coach's corner for any
surface and every season there's a
continental tire that delivers superior
performance unparalleled safety for more
on this from speedway to driveway check
out Continental Tire calm continental
puts you in the driver's seat the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience